estoy muy emocionado porque estamos
empezando el examen número 5 el examen
número 5 y bueno vamos a resolver la
sección número 3 que por cierto está en
la página a 652 y pues empecemos con el
problema número 1 el problema número uno
que dice según una receta francesa
changos según una receta francesa esto
me suena a un 'déjà vu' es como si
estuviera repitiendo el mismo problema
que hicimos en la sección pasada bueno
pero aquí es francesa y la vez pasada
era una receta mexicana a ver vamos a
ver qué dice el problema supongo que en
algo debe de ser distinto según una
receta francesa 25 libras de harina son
necesarias para hacer 300 bolillos sí sí
es distinta porque en la sección pasada
yo hablaba de frijoles
pero bueno hablemos de libras de harina
ok a 25 25 libras
de harina son necesarias para hacer a
300 bolillos 300 bowl y 2 ok de lujo y
después dicen con la misma razón cuántas
libras de harina son necesarias para
hacer 12 bolillos lo que quiero hacer
son 12 bolillos 12 bolillos bolt y josh
y yo lo que necesito saber cuántas
libras así que le voy a poner x libras
voy a necesitar para hacer estos 12
bolillos ok y cómo resolvemos esto bueno
pues esto es una regla de 3 podemos
resolverlo como una regla de 3 porque
sabemos que la razón se va a mantener y
entonces me quedaría este lo voy a
multiplicar por este y después lo voy a
dividir entre este después lo voy a
dividir entre éste para obtener x o
dicho otra manera x va a ser igual a 12
por 25 entre 300 entre 300 por 25 le voy
a poner un por así para que no se
confunda con equis y bueno 12 por 25 me
puedes creer que es 300 300 entre 300 y
esto es igual a 1 tú puedes hacer
cuántos 12 por 25 pero recuerdan que
estamos en los problemas fáciles de esta
sección y los problemas fáciles
requieren un cierto grado de rapidez por
lo tanto 12 por 25 es 300 de hecho es lo
mismo que 6 por 56 por 50 300 entre 300
me da 1 y este es el resultado de este
problema
necesitamos una libra necesitamos una
libra una libra de harina para hacer 12
bolillos ok
solo quiero mencionar que también hay
otra forma de hacerlo nosotros podríamos
decir que 25 25 es a 300 como común
x es a 12 si nosotros ponemos libras
arriba y bolillos abajo vamos a llegar
al mismo resultado de aquí podremos
despejar la x y obtendríamos que x es
exactamente lo mismo que 12 x por 25
entre 300 llegamos a lo mismo es otra
forma de escribir el mismo problema y ya
está así que bueno corremos la pantalla
y pasemos al problema número 2 al
problema número 2 que dice lo siguiente
si x porque si x por jeff esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 10 entonces lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale 2 por x
entre james x cuadrado lo que quiero
saber es cuánto vale esta expresión de
aquí y bueno pues nosotros podemos
utilizar un poco de álgebra para
escribir esto mismo como 2 que
multiplica a x porque cuadrada esto es
como si estuviera dividiendo entre 1
entre 1 todo esto entre james y aquí
podemos utilizar las leyes de los
exponentes si nosotros tenemos de
cuadrada entre bien pues estás de
acuerdo que esto es lo mismo que 2x bien
es decir bien cuadrada entre james es lo
mismo que bien tengo arriba el bien por
game y un aire que divide se cancela una
y solamente me queda una y oye elevado a
la primera potencia pero ya tenemos la
solución 2x james es exactamente lo
mismo que 2 por 10 porque es el dato que
me da acá arriba x por james vale 10 y
entonces 2 por 10 es 20 y el resultado
de toda esta expresión que teníamos en
un principio es simple y sencillamente
20 ya está este es el inciso y aquí
tenemos una respuesta más así que vamos
a hacer el problema número 3 que creo
que me cabe aquí y siento que estoy
hablando un poco chistoso un poco
exitoso porque acabo de ir al dentista
debe de ser por eso que estoy hablando
no se denuncia no se hagamos el problema
número 3 el problema número 3 que dice x
+ james x es igual a 30 a 30 y por otra
parte me dicen que x es más grande que 8
déjame cambiar de color x es más grande
que otro entonces cuál de las siguientes
desigualdades es verdad y son por las
desigualdades que tienen que ver con
james así que vamos a utilizar esta
ecuación de aquí arriba que me queda
yo sé que x más bien esto es igual a 37
aquí restó que de ambos lados de esta
ecuación voy a obtener que x
es igual a 30 menos 30 menos 10
ok y de aquí ya que puedo obtener bueno
yo sé que x es más grande que 8 por lo
tanto 30 menos debe ser más grande que 8
porque esto esto es lo mismo que x esto
es lo mismo que x y lo único que estoy
haciendo es metiéndolo en esta
desigualdad es decir que me va a quedar
que 30 menos 30 menos
esto es más grande que 8 o utilizando un
poco de fiorasi sumo y de ambos lados de
esta desigualdad me va a quedar que 30
es más grande que 8 más bien y ahora sí
restó 8 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad me va a quedar que 30 menos
8 30 menos 8 es 22 22 es más grande que
ya ha dicho de otra manera
james es más pequeño que 22 que 22 y
este es el inciso b ya está recuerda que
en un principio los problemas tienen
soluciones muy fáciles las cuales nos
pueden servir para
un poco de tiempo así que vamos al
siguiente problema déjame borrar la
pantalla y entonces vamos a trabajar con
nuestro cuarto problema el problema
número 4 y es más déjame cambiar de
color a un color que tengan que ver con
pasta de dientes en honor a mi visita al
dentista del día de hoy problema número
4 este cuadro se parece a la pasta de
dientes dicen si tenemos los puntos en
el punto p es el punto 3 2 3 2
ok el punto q el punto q es el punto 72
7.2 perfecto y el punto r
el punto r es el punto 7,4
muy bien y me dicen si tenemos estos
tres puntos cuánto vale el perímetro del
triángulo p q r
me parece una buena idea gráfica estos
tres puntos para ver qué es lo que está
pasando así que déjame hacer a son
positivos todos es pero déjame hacer
aquí mi eje de las 10
y voy a quitar esto de aquí y esto por
acá
ok voy a decir que este es mi eje de las
10 este es mi eje x ok y tengo estos 3
puntos así que vamos a graficar los a
déjame cambiar de color un color que no
sea tan dentífrico algo como este y aquí
voy a tener el primer punto que es el 3
voy a suponer que a mí déjame cambiar a
otro color voy a suponer que aquí es el
valor de 3 en x y por acá por acá tengo
el valor de 2 en 10 por lo tanto aquí
tenemos al punto p aquí está el punto p
es más déjame ponerlo aquí arriba aquí
está nuestro punto p por otra parte
tengo el punto 7,2 así que vamos a
caminar hasta acá hasta que hasta el 7
en x y subimos lo mismo 2 por lo tanto
por aquí está mi punto y por aquí es
también puntocom y después tenemos el
punto r 7.4 es decir nos vamos a mover
de este punto 2 para arriba para acá
donde está el valor de 4 aquí tenemos el
7,4 que va a ser justo este de por aquí
el punto r y es más vamos a trazar las
líneas si otras son las líneas me va a
quedar un triángulo parecido a éste esta
esta y voy a trazar con este color esta
otra línea ok
tengo un triángulo parecido a éste y
vamos a ver qué es lo que podemos
concluir en primer lugar las distancias
de pq
si te das cuenta tenemos la misma altura
solamente estamos caminando cuatro
unidades hacia la derecha por lo tanto
podemos decir que la distancia que el pp
acuse son cuatro unidades porque no
subimos y bajamos nada tenemos la misma
altura ok de qr no caminamos nada ni a
la derecha ni la izquierda simple y
sencillamente subimos subimos de dos a
cuatro es decir subimos dos unidades por
lo tanto la distancia que hay del punto
cuál punto r son dos unidades y la
distancia que hay del punto r al punto p
pues bueno justo eso es tras lo que
vamos pero lo primero que quiero que
veas es que aquí tenemos un triángulo y
ese triángulo es un triángulo rectángulo
aquí tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados
como estas son rectas son
perpendiculares porque esta no cambia en
el eje y esta no cambia en el eje x
entonces podemos concluir que este es un
triángulo rectángulo y todos los
triángulos rectángulos cumplen el
teorema de pitágoras y el teorema de
pitágoras que nos dice bueno pues date
cuenta que esta está de aquí es la
hipotenusa y entonces tenemos que elevar
un cateto al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado ya
este sumarle el otro cateto el 4 elevado
al cuadrado el 4 elevado al cuadrado y
esto nos va a dar la hipotenusa elevada
al cuadrado vamos a suponer que la
hipotenusa se llama x la hipotenusa se
llama xy entonces 2 al cuadrado más 4 al
cuadrado
esto es igual a x cuadrada o dicho de
otra manera 4 + 16 esto es igual a x
cuadrada o dicho de otra manera
x cuadrada es igual a 20 o si pasamos
este cuadrado como raíz cuadrada me va a
quedar que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 20 pero bueno ésta es de las típicas
raíces que se puede simplificar esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarnos
a la raíz cuadrada de 4 por 5 de 4 por 5
y esto es lo mismo que sacar la raíz a 4
que es 2 y sacar la raíz a 5 que es pues
la raíz de 5 eso no se puede simplificar
es decir que la raíz de 20 es lo mismo
que dos veces la raíz de 5 por lo tanto
x vale dos veces la raíz de cinco dos
veces la raíz de cinco y de hecho creo
que la parte más difícil de todo este
problema es ver que la raíz de 20 es dos
veces la raíz de cinco muchas veces les
cuesta mucho trabajo simplificar una
raíz cuadrada pasar de esta raíz de 20 a
estas dos veces la raíz de 5 es un
relajo así que vamos a ponerlo aquí con
un poco más de calma si yo tengo 20 lo
voy a poner por acá si yo tengo 20 lo
podemos descomponer en factores vamos a
descomponerlo en factores primos 2020
tiene mitad la mitad de 2010 10 10
también y mitad la mitad de 10 es 5 y 5
pues 5 tiene solamente quinta quinta y
sobra 1 es decir que el 20
lo podemos ver igual que 2 por 2 por 5 o
dicho de otra manera el 20 lo podemos
ver como 2 al cuadrado por 5 así que
igual y de esta manera se te hace mucho
más fácil poder encontrar la raíz
cuadrada de un número y así poderla
simplificar si 20 es igual a 2 al
cuadrado por 5 entonces ahora lo ponen
para aquí y me va a quedar 4 por 5 o
dicho de otra manera dos veces la raíz
de 5 muy bien esta es otra forma de
poder simplificar una raíz cuadrada pero
lo que nos piden no es la raíz cuadrada
de 20 sino cuánto vale el perímetro de
este triángulo pues vamos a sacarlo el
perímetro de este triángulo es cuatro
más dos más dos veces la raíz de 5 es
decir que el perímetro del perímetro es
lo mismo que 6
dos veces la raíz de 5 estos otros no se
pueden sumar porque este no tiene una
raíz de 5 y vamos a ver nuestras
respuestas o de hecho de hecho hasta
hicimos demás porque la respuesta es el
inciso c que dice 6 + la raíz de 20 6
más la raíz de 20 es mi respuesta que
por cierto pues esto es lo mismo que 6
más dos veces la raíz de 5 estas dos
cosas son exactamente iguales solamente
que en el libro no simplificaron la raíz
bueno son dos puntos distintos de llegar
a la misma respuesta y ya están a déjame
borrar esto y vamos a poner aquí el
problema número 5 antes de que se me
acabe el tiempo y voy a cambiar de color
a un color un poco más colorido así que
bueno quitemos los colores de pasta de
dientes y vamos a hacer el siguiente
problema y tiene una sucesión las
sucesiones 8 17 26 35 44 y esta sucesión
sigue y sigue y sigue y nos dicen los
primeros 5 términos de una sucesión se
muestran a continuación es decir estos 5
este 4 está muy raro pero bueno sin
contar el primero cada término se
obtiene sumando 9 al término anterior es
decir 17 es lo mismo que 8 + 917 más 9
es 26 26 más 9 es 35 35 más 9 es 44
etcétera
cuál es el término cuál es el término
que es igual yo lo que quiero saber es
cuál es el término que es 8
más 26 - 1 esto por 9 wow este problema
esta sorprendente yo lo que quiero saber
es qué término es este número de clip
este es mi término 1 mi segundo terminó
tercero cuarto quinto y éste está que
terminó es es decir para que en este es
a n
y muy interesante
a ver vámonos con calma vamos a ver
primero qué pasa con esta sucesión que
tengo yo aquí arriba vamos a utilizarlo
así que déjame hacer una pequeña tabla
por aquí una pequeña tabla por aquí
aunque hay algo así y algo así y en la
primera columna voy a poner aquí el
término el término término y bueno voy a
poner el término 1 el término 2 el
término 3 el término 4 y voy a ver si
encuentro el patrón el término 1 2 3 4 y
aquí voy a poner el valor del término el
valor del término del término ok bueno
el término 1 vale es el término inicial
y por lo tanto lo voy a poner solamente
como 8 ok el término 2 el término 2 vale
vale 17 pero date cuenta que 17 es lo
mismo que 8 más
9 o dicho de otra manera para que lo
veas de una forma más intuitiva esto es
lo mismo que 8
9 x 1
es decir que si nosotros tenemos el
término 2 vamos a sumarle solamente una
vez 9 vamos a ver qué pasa con el
término 3 igual y con el término 3 es
mucho más claro lo que está pasando el
término 3 se llama 26-26 que por cierto
esto es lo mismo que 17 más 9 o dicho de
otra manera esto es lo mismo que 8 + 9 +
9 o lo podemos ver como 8
dos veces 92 por 9 cuando tengo el
tercer término le sumo a 82 veces 9 a
ver si yo tengo el término 4 que es 35
el 35 lo podemos escribir
creo que ya podemos tener una intuición
del patrón esto es lo mismo que 8 más y
aquí es el término 4 pues entonces le
tengo que quitar 1 me va a quedar 3 por
9 y bueno usando esta misma lógica te
vas a poder dar cuenta que en efecto 83
por 9 es lo mismo que 35 es decir que el
término en el término n lo puedo
encontrar como como 8 más
algo por 9 más algo por 9 el término n
va a ser 8 + n 1 en el -1 por 9 es decir
estamos quitando 1 al término 1 al
término para encontrar cuantas veces
tenemos que multiplicar por nueve le
quitamos 1 a 2 y llegamos a uno le
quitamos 1 a 3 y llegamos a 2 le
quitamos 14 y llegamos a 3 le quitamos 1
ene y llegamos a n 1 por 9 y bueno
utilizando esta misma patrón esta misma
lógica
podemos decir que n en este caso vale
aquí el término 4 es 4 menos uno por 9
aquí el término n s n menos 1 por 9 aquí
tengo 26 menos 1 por 9 por lo tanto
estamos hablando del término 26 el
término 26 es la respuesta de éste el
problema número 526 menos 1 por 9 por lo
tanto este es mi término y ya está y
también ya se me acabó el tiempo así que
seguimos haciendo el siguiente problema
en el siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima